[Musica]
[Applauso]
bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j
è come avevo promesso mesi e mesi e mesi
anni e secoli e
arriva finalmente sono su penombra dopo
secoli di attese che avevo promesso
facciamo normale ma iniziamo subito così
almeno non vi annoiate le messe alla
commissione febbraio del 2000 dicevo
queste penombra overture non è penombra
back blog che sarebbe il primo che avevo
fatto perché quello sarebbe secondo
capitolo
poi vi spiego meglio look magari quanto
riguarda il mio ruolo in questa faccenda
non farò certo lo stesso errorino ma non
so chi sei e larga pochi metri nel giro
di otto che molti mi trovo su una barca
perché in 12 ore mi avrebbe condotto nei
meandri del mio passato
ok penombra ok come narratore faccio
pena diciamo questo è il primo capitoli
penombra ovvero il primissimo gioco che
è che è uscito e come abbiamo fatto
prima era penombra black bloc deciso di
iniziare questo è finire questo come
l'ex dell intero per poi magari
continuare nell'altro se vi piace questo
finalmente attracchiamo meglio iniziare
a preparare le cose le mie cose come a
casa non posso raccogliere gli oggetti
utilizzando man sinistra hanno posto
raccoglie oggetti di casa dove gli
oggetti vicino a usando maldestro uguale
agli altri sommano sappiamo di avere un
blocco note portata di mano n ok ho
lasciato una scritta peccato la pazienza
perfetta ora che ci siamo
la vj super non browser terriccio a
lanciare latina random questa dovrebbe
essere la mappa però non si capisce
siamo in groenlandia
perché devi andare in groenlandia amato
ericsson ragazzi finalmente in italiano
perché una capisco perché primo capitolo
non hanno fatto in italiano è il secondo
no e anche il terzo non perché poi c'è
anche un terzo non hanno fatto in
italiano gli altri
ok riusciamo cioè cosa devo fare qua
devo a devastare fosse a dormire
fantastico devo rimanere a devo prendere
cuscino ok
andiamo a pescare trote ragazzi come
inizio è fantastico perché già non so
cosa fare siamo solo a un jack daniels
era un jack dance come sprecare l'ottimo
wesley non c'è altro dice che lei a
parte ubriacarvi cosa posso fare qua
dentro di interessante
salvagente
a chiave chiave del lucchetto
ok
qui è piuttosto poi la torcia questo me
tornarmi utile e le batterie extra poi
c'è sta roba qui che sarebbe il bengala
conduce il ponte ma non affronterà le
intemperie finché non sarà strettamente
necessario ok
e se io le intemperie volessi
affrontarla adesso torcia possa
accendere spegnere l'inventario
da stoffe e con via professione
ho tutto ciò di cui ho bisogno di
muovermi prima che faccia buio non la
prendi la giacca nova dovuto io ragazzi
posto non appena scesi dalla barca nel
mezzo della tempesta mia si conta della
seduta del consiglio si va ci siano
ragazzi siamo usciti è ora brevi fa
molto freddo non solo mi trovo bisogno
di un riparo perché la barca ti ha
completamente lasciato nel mezzo della
groenlandia
perché rispondete voi ragazzi non ne ho
la più pallida idea essendo abbiamo
andato a me la tecno post recarsi
direttamente noi proseguiamo c'è ma
questa di voler un po che importa mi
servo riparo sempre a chiusura il
ghiaccio non riuscire ad entrare
aprite c'è del ghiaccio fa il fuoco
il fuoco col venga la quale trovare
qualcosa c'è una roccia qualcosa del
genere
freddo senza freno anch'io ho guardato
raga datemi il mio regno per un sasso
per prova avevo di metterli lanciarci
tecnico tengo premuto
domanda internazionale si dovrebbe poter
riuscire ad afferrare la perché vediamo
se riesco a spaccandola qua quasi
pensavo di dover c lanciare un pinguino
raga allora vediamoli
mentre parigi ragazzi piano
le stiamo per aprire una botola perfetto
ok è vero che ce la possiamo fare
perfetto apt aprile a brighi a fiere
andiamo infilarci nei condotti perfetto
ragazzi stiamo entrando in un posti
sconosciuti come è solito fare per noi
perché ovviamente no i migliori moro
entriamo le botole oscure ok 6 caldo
adesso a posto casa
fantastico la mia testa ma riesco a
credere che di esse se voi vi siete
natale caduta è caduto non riesce a
scendere una scala a ma era rotta
va bene al massimo possiamo sempre
uscire mi faccio strada poi barile occhi
ai ragazzi vediamo di uscire di qua
perché già non mi piace non siamo che
non siamo neanche entrati ragazzi ma io
voglio già uscire allora scatole vuote
perfetto ha già trovato un passaggio
segreto ragazzi neanche cinque minuti di
gameplay e già ci sono spaccati vecchie
come sono riusciti a spostarlo a mani
nude a jade ha stracciato boom
ma cosa sto facendo stai tentando di
aprirlo magari cos'è razzetto martello
perfetto vediamo posso citare matteo
tende pronto ma sinistra posso caricare
indietro momento il manzo ds quindi di
sinistra stessi si va bene vediamo
ok vediamo se riesco a spaccare tipo ok
vediamo se riesco a spaccare no e giù
con una mano e meglio
ok ok sto spaccando nel modo più
sbagliato che esiste perfetto ci entrò
dopo perché è molto invitante però
preferisco farne a meno per adesso io
sei scarpino e togliere sto cazzo di
martello perfetto quando un attimo di là
perché mi ispirava questa stanza molto
bella e bloccata dietro non c'è niente
vero c'è un vasetto perfetto ormai c'è
un occhio ragazzi per i giochi horror
riesco a capire dove sono nascoste red e
gli utensili
si chiama c qui sotto come senza motivo
io vado di qua ok
questa è la stanza di prima bloccata ok
ok me ne torno ve ne torno me ne torno
me ne torno me ne torno ne torno
oddio blocca lorca blocca blocca sera
non si vede niente tra l'altro è di
legno
non so cos'è era ragazzi ma non ci
voglio entrare lì dentro fammi uscire
cos'è questo mega temperamatite sembra
una specie di aster acciaio
ok allora lo giro e cosa mi serve gira
restare ragazzi ok adesso a sia aperto
c'è anche buttato giù il barile che sta
scendendo giustamente ok ho saltato tipo
dieci stanze che probabilmente erano
utili per oggetti robe del genere sono
andato subito nella stanza in cui dovevo
andare cosa pessima in un gioco horror
perché ti servono gli oggetti che devi
prendere però io me ne sono altamente
[ __ ] ero sbagliato mi sono segnato
l'appunto non si sa mai cosa è segnato
lettera d'amore della moglie del
pescatore in entrata alla caverna è
crollata devo trovare un'altra strada
questo ti si è segnato minchia che genio
di sotto potrebbe dirci qualunque cosa
gli eroi son ci sono solo i film di
hollywood e nelle fiabe ma ci sono anche
qui su penombra
non voglio correre rischi se dovessi
incontrare qualcosa non durerà in
nemmeno un secondo attenzione le
festività sono emenike difese semmai
qualcosa dovrebbe sbucare in avanti
migliora regione nascosto si sarebbero
le cose di due mesi alla fine è bloccata
sono in trappola tanto per cambiare da
dove siamo arrivati ragazzi non c'è un
punto ma noi proseguiamo nascondermi
cerca poi di secondi perfettamente
immobile con significato di dovrei di
acquistare la visione notturna patto di
essere immobile si sono alle stesse
regole di euro
storage i rom molti di voi ragazzi mi
hanno detto che non son riusciti a
finirlo perché li metteva troppa stizza
tra virgolette non so come ma adesso
vedremo se sarà così sta lanterna è lì
solo per bellezza non la prendere non si
sa mai che diventa troppo facile storage
e rum
ci siamo quasi ai ragazzi
ok storage giro un perfetto storici come
sarebbe qualcosa perfetto bella piena di
provviste tra l'altro una scarpa mi
porto la scarpa scappava è contro la sc
qualcuno non c'è nessuno hai detto ok mi
fido apriamo grazie scarpa mi sia stata
utilissima ok
bene a questi così qua c'erano anche in
un altro penombra oddio che luce mai
capito che cosa servissero cosa diavolo
è successo mi è sembrata una non mi
sembra una grande idea infatti non ho
capito anche qui che cosa servono raga
se qualcuno di voi sa che cosa servono
sti cosi me lo dica questo è stato
sentito tipo o un topo un mezzo cani non
so che cosa era ho sentite ci passano
scarpa aspetta
[Musica]
raga io sono sicuro di aver capito c'è
un tipo che piange lì dentro perché
rivuole la sua scarpa e l'ha lasciata
fuori gli hotel arido volentieri
aspettate ok se contento adesso cosa
vuoi anche l'altra lido anche l'altra
ok le scarpe ce l'hai non sei contento
[Musica]
ma sembra tanto contento ragazzi io me
ne vado di qua perché ciò stizza ok
perfetto
ricapitolando abbiamo trovato delle
scarpe l'abbiamo di date al tipo lì
dentro produttiva piange
cazzo cos'è un cane un cane un cane un
cane un cane un cane prima nasconderci
qua è un cane era un cane non è un cane
perché gesù non mi sono mai sentito così
spaventati vita mia il mio cuore va a
mille
la cosa si avvicina troppo nascondiglio
meglio non ci accade da un occhiata
potrebbe gettare nel panico per me
sarebbe la fine
ok c'è un cane ragazzi perché c'è un
cane nelle miniere perche ci sono i cani
nelle miniere non ha senso però i cani
non mi pare che facciano paura cioè mi
sembra un normalissimo cane non ha nulla
di strano
credo la luce
lo seguo non meglio lo fosse migliore
seguirlo ragazzi ne vado di qui dove
andiamo di qua andiamo al workshop ok
sta tornando sta tornando sta tornando
sto tornando tn unica di carico va
benissimo
perfetto non andarsene subito office
andiamo a mi sembra di aver trovato a
pensava si dovesse salvare la macchina
da scrivere tipo tipo residenti vol
va bè ragazzi probabilmente qui troverò
qualche chiave per poi passare nella
stanza successiva come inizierà molto
soft perché ovviamente il gioco ci deve
far capire chi meno come si gioca che
bisogna nasconda si accetta quindi penso
che la prossimo episodio inizieranno
veramente gli infarti o comunque questi
episodi perché da qui perché sono gli
amanti troppo se il progetto video
lasciato mi piace la pagina facebook che
l'ha trovata in descrizione quella di
famiglia e tv e se volete sapere quando
alcuni video molto prima di tutti gli
altri mettete mi piace lì o se volete fa
mille domande niente ci vediamo prossimo
video belle ragazze
[Musica]
ah cazzo no no
no no no no no no no no no no